you
people shopping for summer fruits may
notice peaches are selling for higher
prices a double whammy of unexpected
weather destroyed most of the peach
crops in the southeast
last month wholesale prices for a case
of Georgia peaches reportedly rose from
roughly $20 to about $30 now that's an
increase of 50%
mark Strassmann is at a peach farm in
new salad Georgia with how they're
handling the downturn mark good morning
good morning
right now Pickers should be harvesting
this orchard but take a look at how puny
this peach is it's worthless and it has
plenty of company tree after tree
orchard after orchard here tells the
same story no peach is worth picking a
multi-million dollar disaster anything
better than a Georgia Peach absolutely
not that's the best there is Lee Dickey
a fifth-generation family farmer knows
what a difference a year makes
this was Dickey Farms last year a
spectacular crop the family's thousand
acres of orchards produced 8 million
pounds of sweet Georgia peaches this
year's crop two million pounds a 75
percent drop take this tree for instance
Dickey says it's peaches right now
should be the size of a golf ball you
would hope right now you'd have about
four to five hundred peaches of that
size on this tree what do you have and
you really don't have any like this tree
in particular has zero mature or growing
peaches here's why
wacky winter weather confused then
killed the crop first unseasonable warm
temperatures deprived the crop of needed
chill hours followed by freezing
temperatures in mid-march that stretched
across the southeast when you have a
freeze you know within a couple days
what's alive and what's dead the Dickey
family's loss could top five million
dollars Gary black Georgia's Agriculture
Commissioner told us the state could
lose eighty percent of this year's crop
that's representative of you know
hundreds of millions of dollars in
Georgia's economy I really think you're
going to see supply drop off after the
fourth you
and that that'll just mean that we're
preparing for 2018 2018
Justin Dickson's customers want to order
his peach salad this summer the
executive chef at the shed a restaurant
in Atlanta has become a peach hoarder
we are the Peach State so we kind of
have to have them so you just grab it as
many as you can
yeah yeah you you stop pile them and you
pickle them or you make purees or ice
creams or whatever you can before
they're gone Georgia's prime peach
season typically runs June to mid August
but this year by early July Dickey
expects to have nothing left to ship for
consumers that could mean a summer that
will taste a little less sweet Georgia
farmers have it bad but in South
Carolina which actually grows more
peaches they have it worse 90% of that
crop was destroyed there is some good
news
California the country's leading peach
producer had a great crop this year but
foodies who prefer the sweetness of a
good southern peach may have to settle
for watermelon Gail peach and watermelon
not the same thing I love a good peach
yeah so do I they bite you
nothing like a southern peach should I
like watermelon do I like watermelon -
mmm I love me some watermelon yeah like
a peach upside down thank you Mark